[音楽]
例えば
あなたが大学生のとしてん
2つの会社から内定をもらっていたと思う
1社目は使っ
あなたは正直今会社の本来をめちゃくちゃ面白そうだと思っ
もしかしたら大外のアプリになるかもしれない
でも出来たばかりの会社ですからね
いかんせんファンデー
もしかしたら来年にお父さんしているかもしれません
一方合意しては剣豪
誰もが名前を知っている良い方です
きっと安定してるでしょ
でもあなたは業務内容正直つまらないと思う
この2つから就職先を選べと言われたらあなたはを
撮っちゃいられません
5秒放射います理由と一緒にちょっと考えてみてください
を
43分
exe
どちらもいいんですよこれあなたなりの答えを出せばいいと思うんですけど
奥この選び方で全体に皆さんにしてほしくないで上がるんです
それがこれ
不満だから銀行にしようって言われたか
これだけは良いん
今日つまりいただいたわりと若い人が多いと思います大学生結構入れてきました
若い皆さんの人生を決めるのか不安であってはならないと
そう思います
それはそうなんじゃないのってみんな思うかもしれませんでもね実際にはあまりにも
多くの人が
半によって人生を決めてるんです
なさいっ
こういう人がいるからですよね
いろんな不安はを巡ろうとなっ
これは全て僕が大学4年生の時就職しないで生きていこうって決めたとき
実際に言われた言葉です
こうやって不安を煽られるからみんな不安で親戚でちゃう
でね言っておきたいのはこういうことを言ってくることなんてさ
結構立派な音目に見えているかもしれない
でも実は違うんですって話
こういう人たちは僕が不安ゾンビんで選んで大人のです
競合が皆さんにお話ししたいテーマをこの不安ゾンビとも頂いたん
フランゾンビに負けない正本山じゃない
というメインテーブルを
不安ソンビンで謎の言葉導入しちゃったんだよ
ちょっと説明します1ゾンビとは何だっ
これググったらなきゃいけません僕が作ったこと思う
なのでお話しますファンゾンビとこういう流れをたどるのことだと思う
不安敗北した人たちです
さっきの選択しているなら不安だから銀行にしようと不安で決めちゃう
敗北すると彼らはどうなんだ
虚しい韓国暮らしを送ることになります
音が
誰かって思ったのかなもうちょっと面白い切られたんじゃないかなっ
母屋からん
ところが恐ろしいもので人間ってそれをだんだん正当化するようになるんですね
でも今までの大臣でないからか
あんまり楽しくないけど持たれシーンじゃないからこれ正解だったんだろうなと思うん
でありません
あっちを選んだけど大自然とかもしれないから
これでよかったんだろう
そうすると彼らのは驚くべきことに
あなたもそっちに引き込もうとしてくれん
お前そんな無駄てだろうか
ちゃんというか体との就職者がいいんじゃないのってそっちの道にありませんよね
を9月音便でことを使った理由皆さんも大たいですか
これゾンビの一緒じゃんっ
人がゾンビに襲われてその人もゾンビになりまた別の人をゾンビにする
そういう流れです
この不安ゾンビが今どんどん増えている
ありとあらゆる皆さんがどんどん不安ゾンビになってい
このサイクルを繰り返して
大学生の皆さんですよ
ファンゾンビになりつつあるよ
僕はそれを狩り止めたくている今日来ました
不安ゾンビに負けない成分戦略
皆さんにお伝えしますきっと役に立つ内容だと思います
覚えて巻いてください
さて偉そうに言ってるんですけど僕は誰バナーということでちょっと自己紹介させて
いただきます
堀本県と申します
遊びづくりを仕事にしています
遊び作れて例えばなんですがいい
または困難ですん
去年の7月にあった
枯葉打ってるじゃないですか
よく駅前で元気な大学生のかやってる奴
通行人とアブラっ
愛国みてね正直全然もらいたいなぁ
さても農協の漫画なんか面白くいけないかなぁと思って思いついたダジャレが古い入っ
結果がこうなっちゃうかっ
や感じさせます
こんなダジャレの企画とかただけいろんなことやってます
全部やれていると思うんだけどもうちょい関西行っちゃう
地域お料理津々浦々いろんな遊びを二つできます
あとは交流があるらしいんでそんな事やった
あんな馬鹿してくださいん
デコイ事してるとねっ
こういうことして駅で待っ生計立ててますか優等
皆様と2台たい一つの疑問が浮かぶんですん
だから
q & a のコーナーです
みんな今実はたまりいうか電気もあると思う
それを当ててだってお金にしてるんですよ
猫と戯れ
早っ
お金を通らせませんこれいろんな答えが変わるんですよ
朝鮮分やるぜ
そうですね
もらっています
いろんな人がいろんな形でおらっ
皆さん on twitter
twitter でこういう投稿録するんですよ
遊び使っていますねを白くするんでお金くださいん
操作訪ね結婚踏み込んでみたりするんですよ
調子につきの悪い月あるんですけど先月は調子良くてですね
6万円ぐらいやらないとかと造り込まれていました
まぁこんな感じです
他にもいろんなもらいだろうしていますこんな感じで開催
ん
こういうことをしてますって言うとね
当然されちゃいましたね
不安も追ってくる大人がめっちゃ近くにいっぱいあってくるんですよ
不安ゾンビにめちゃくちゃも花を添えます
戸田山が日本市場をされてもしれません
でも1回も負けたことありません
肝臓にも勝ち続けてきました
そんな僕だから皆さん館ゾンビに勝つ方法を教えられると思っています
頭やら数
国家問題ですよ
よく覚えてません
ゲームなんだ列車です
ファンゾンビにはある弱点があったです
この弱点を突けば絶対負けない
活動もできます
弱店舗はないな
それはー
彼ら頭を使っていないと思う
赤間を使ってない彼
いうことってこういう事ですよ
こんなと思うこんなとかこんなのとか
本日は前二のことなんですよ
彼らは鎌を使ってないから
世間普通に信じられている普通のことしか言わないん
それを何度が掛けれて大パーティー言ってるだけそういう感じです
だからこの不安ゾンビに勝つための方法は進化です
たった一つの東京もでございます
たった一つの時を持っていただいてください
タイプ
ロン
カーンゾンビに勝つための時は論理です
普通のことを普通に信じ込んでいる不安ゾンビたちは
自分のアタマで一生懸命考えて出した結論をしゃべってるわけじゃないんです
なんとなくみんながこうだって言ってるよねっていうことを口に出してるだけだから
みんなで一生懸命考えたのに戦えないんです
だからもし不安も煽られてるんだぞこれになりそうなのって思ったら自分なりの論理を
組み立てください
そしてそれを続けてみてください
あなたは5校しちゃいましたけどを書こうここだと思うんです
ここでこうだからこうじゃないですか
ちゃんと日の整然としたあなたの理論をぶつければ彼らは反論できません
自分の頭で考えて出した問題じゃないから
カーンゾンビと戦うための使ったひとつの時はが多いんですっ
これを思ってください
を言ってもですねあんまりピンと来ないな方が多いと思う
僕の前の例を紹介します
最後に僕の具体例を紹介します
僕はどう与論てどういう動きで満足度とかだというか
僕が高くといういつも使っているときはこれです
遊びの時代がもうそこまで来てい
ってことです
誰かって
遊びのしたいってまず何段階かと思うん
遊びをした人はみんな遊びしかやらなくなるじゃないところです
これがもうそこまで来ていると思っています
なぜかっ
3つあります
を7方法にしてきたのでぜひ皆さん覚えてください
もいらない仕事捉えるツールがあるのですか
この3つに置くで遊びの時代が来ていると思います
ん
下りに見ていきましょうものに入らない
ものが入らないし長く言われています
特に若い人の間で顕著だと言ってます
例えばさん家これらがすごいわかりやすいです
昔は結構でかいですんでいいですんでそれをしています
言われてましたけど今の人たちで結構そうじゃないですよね
最低限でいいじゃん退任ハウスちっちゃい家なんかもやってます
僕は部屋まで日常ホンレイいいじゃんと思っています
実際に一畳半の部屋につい最近までですね
ただ7月今年の7月まで積んでました
めちゃくちゃ会でです婚礼じゃんと思っ
2点目に仕事が捉える
これも皆さん耳たぶじゃないんじゃね人工知能のがロボットから仕事を奪っていきます
下言われてますよね
これは10年以内に亡くなる確率が高いってオックスフォード大学が発表した
仕事の一覧です
なくなっ
最後ツールがあります
10代ではインターネットで非常にいうを集めになります
多くの人にあっという間で情報と受けられます
この3点によって
何が起こっん
web スタッフ様同じことを
を指しますこの2つ業務です
人類がやらなきゃいけないことがなくなります
だってそうでしょ
ものがいっぱい必要だったしたいです
使わないじゃない
ガンガン働いてもうをたくさん作らなきゃいけないからでも今は
ものがいらない子になってます最低限でいい子たい
そして仕事が取られます人間がやらなきゃいけなかった立つようとか仕事が全部
人工知能やロボットが代替するようになります
これにを伝えにじゃなきゃいけないことはなくなります
した2あるこれによって何がこの額さっきお見せしました
朝ネタは何がもらえるようになります僕の酒をツイッターもレイバーが安いですね
楽しいことやるよこれが咲いてるからご覧痛いします
これによって何が起こるかっ
皆さん想像してください
今皆さんの頭の中にあるやらなきゃいけないこと
全部なになります
やがてに良くなります
そして遊んでたら何かこらえよう位
その状態で皆さんも何をしますか
遊ぶしかないん
遊びの時代がもうそこまで来ているんです
だから
皆さん
千葉好きなそれは何ですか
一番ワクワクした瞬間は何ですか
5瞬間のことだけ
考えればいいんです
不安に水
悩む必要があります
以上これが僕がいつも不安装備とたこの時に使っているろんでした
こうやって外さなきゃいけました
これ内容を守りなんですけど今の僕の論理に共感する人もいればしない人が大勢いると
思います
それでいいと思います
でもファン装備と戦う戦うことができる武器は論文だけだということをお伝えした
とおりです
だから納得いかなかった人もぜひ自分なりのローンにをつくってみてください
そして不安便人生を決めないよう気を付けて下さい
不安ゾンビに負けないよ
あなたなりの論理を磨いてください
皆さんの人生が
代わりにまみれたものじゃなく
わくわくに溢れたものになること
心からになっています
ありがとうございます
[拍手]